thank you so much sean that was
fantastic
i especially love it when we have
somebody speaking that makes the 10 000
year
reference of long now seem like a blink
of an eye so i'd love to welcome you for
our q
a hi xander thanks very much for having
me here i think you started you started
to answer this question but i
maybe if we put it back in terms of the
egg it will make more sense
to me at least which is that so that
there's an egg that gets cracked and
goes into higher entropy state but
there's also
the part of the egg that we didn't talk
about which is the formation of the egg
in the chicken
um and i think you talked about this as
you know as humans
are formed into life there's and is that
a is that a process that is going
towards higher entropy or lower entropy
when the creation of something like the
egg before it gets cracked
you know if you include a large enough
system
the only processes that we have are ones
going to higher entropy there's no
processes that go to lower entropy
you can have an entropy decrease like i
said in the talk you can uh
clean your room that's okay you can take
a bottle of water
yeah you can put it in the refrigerator
it will cool off its entropy will go
down that's all allowed
but it's only because it's increasing
the entropy somewhere else
the reason why you can't cool your
living room
by putting a refrigerator in there and
opening the front door
is because there's more heat coming out
of the back than there is cool
going out the front so overall if you
include enough stuff
entropy always goes up and that's why i
don't like to think about
life or other complicated things as
fighting against
the increase of entropy because that's a
losing battle we're not going to win
that one
what we can do is take advantage of the
evolution
that is caused by entropy increasing and
make that into something interesting and
important and meaningful
well that that example the refrigerator
is really helpful it's like why you
can't put a fan on a sailboat and
get anywhere that's right uh right so
that that that actually makes a lot of
sense so
and that you can do things in a
localized system but you're basically
robbing
that from somewhere else in the larger
system um
yeah when we started uh building this
ten thousand year clock project
one of the first uh material scientists
that i spoke to
gave me the best picture in my head of
how we should think about
materials that are going to last over 10
000 years he said
everything is burning just at different
rates and fundamentally like everything
is just oxidizing
and you can choose kind of which which
materials that you want to use and how
fast they you want them to oxidize
but it was it was kind of ringing to me
as you as as you spoke because uh that's
our that's our entropic process that we
get to fight
when building something well and they
weren't probably even worrying about the
fact that eventually we'll fall into a
black hole and be radiated away
into intergalactic space but the it's a
very vivid that's a 10 billion euros
right yeah i mean everything is burning
everything is running down the most
solid thing in the world
is not 100 static that's uh that's
physics for you and the
the ultimate state we think of the
universe is going to be nothing but
empty space
if you're not empty space you're not
done evolving yet
and how is it that we know um that the
moment of the big bang was so much lower
entropy than now what's what's our
what's our evidence of this
well there's sort of a two-part little
dance that we have to go through that's
a very interesting uh difficult question
one is
we can just look at it right we have
data
we have the images of the cosmic
microwave background the leftover
radiation from the big bang
so we know what the conditions or we
think we know what the conditions were
like near the big bang okay and we can
calculate their entropy we have formulas
for doing this and
the reason why well sorry that was a bit
of an exaggeration
we have formulas that work in certain
circumstances we don't have the once and
for all
formula for the entropy of the universe
as a whole but what we can do is to say
what's the entropy of a black hole okay
a single black
hole you know our galaxy the milky way
galaxy has a supermassive black hole in
the middle that is
millions of times the mass of the sun
you can calculate the entropy of that
stephen hawking told us how to do that
the entropy of that one black hole in
the middle of our galaxy
is bigger than the entropy of the whole
universe
near the big bang so we know that
however you want to
talk about it the entropy of the
universe near the big bang was
much lower than it was today it would
have been higher if there had been black
holes around but there weren't
and that when you say a black hole has
more entropy than it
than another one are you saying that
it's it's it's more the milk has swirled
more into that coffee like you're seeing
a more
homeostatic kind of version of it you
know i can't tell you the answer to that
one that's above my pay rate so
this is one of the this is one of the
reasons why this whole subject is so
fascinating you know in the 1970s
stephen hawking and some friends of his
noticed that there was an analogy
between the behavior of black holes and
the laws of thermodynamics
and they just said oh look that's a fun
analogy and then jacob beckenstein who
was a graduate student at the time
said you know what i don't think it's an
analogy i think it's actually an
equivalence
black holes really are thermodynamic
systems with entropy and so forth
and hawking got annoyed by this he said
that's nonsense if black holes had an
entropy
they would have to radiate they would
have a temperature they would give off
radiation and everyone knows that black
holes don't radiate
so he sat down to prove it and he ended
up proving they do radiate he invented
hawking radiation which is one of the
greatest discoveries of the
second half of the 20th century in
physics but
we still don't know what that entropy
represents in a very real sense so what
we have from
hawking and beckenstein are formulas
that we can plug in we can tell you very
accurately how much
entropy is in a black hole just as we
can tell you the entropy of a cup of
coffee
but for the cup of coffee we can say oh
because there's molecules there's
cream molecules and there's coffee
molecules and if you say well what is it
that are the equivalents of the
molecules
in the case of the black hole we just
don't know right now
interesting and i wonder if you know
part of the issue is that we don't have
good visualization tools for
that we keep showing time on a timeline
um for instance but
have you come up are there good
visualization tools that would kind of
break this
paradigm better or show it better for
people
you know it's a good question i don't
have any good uh
answers as to what a good visualization
tool would be
what i find very interesting is that
there is no universality
in how people visualize time so if you
become a professional physicist and you
specialize in relativity or cosmology
right
space time and the expansion of the
universe all that thing
and you want to draw a picture of the
universe what we call a space-time
diagram
for you time runs upward from the bottom
to the top
in every space-time diagram ever written
if you're a particle physicist and you
have two particles bumping into each
other and scattering off and you want to
draw a picture of that a finemen diagram
to you time runs from left to right if
you're a computer scientist
talking about how algorithms go to you
time runs from top to bottom
so that there are different ways that we
represent
time in space and now uh analogically
and uh there's a whole nother you know
hour-long talk to be given about how
that gets represented in language
different spatial metaphors different
temporal metaphors
and so whatever our metaphors are it's
hard for us to break free of them
you might be right maybe there's a
better one that would help us think
about this
right and you mentioned how time and
linguistics are are
linked and i mean i assume that also you
know one of the things that we do some
language projects here at long now and
it's it's often said that you know if
you lose a language you lose a world
view
as well and have you found that there's
other cultures either
indigenous or modern that kind of
inherently
understand time that more the way
physics physicists do ah
so i don't know i what what i what i
completely agree with is the idea that
different cultures do
understand time very differently um and
some of them might become
closer to physics than to sort of what
we might call the modern physics
attitude toward it but i'm just not
educated enough on
uh what those are you know and and if
there are any
you know i don't want to give either our
culture or any other cultures
too much credit because you know
when it comes to things like the
large-scale history of the universe
um well there's two options the universe
is eternal or it's finite in time and so
some
cultures had stories where it was finite
it had a beginning
other stories where it was infinite and
one of them's going to be right but
there's only two choices
neither one of them were on the basis of
data from telescopes right because even
right now
we do not know whether the universe
truly had a beginning or whether the big
bang was just a phase
so i think that there's lots of
different metaphors lots of different
stories lots of different cultural ways
of thinking about time
but even modern physics doesn't have the
right picture yet
so i'm not going to give credit to
anybody quite yet
right yeah we had a speaker um early on
who uh
dan everett who studies the braha in
central or south america and they have a
very very clearly a very different
conception of time i'm not sure if it's
more aligned with physics or not
but much less about past and future
we have a great question here from
raphael
from the facebook feed says hi i'm a
teenager it's very common for people my
age to go through existential crisis
because of how massively large the
universe is
and how little significance our
individual lives have
is feeling my newt the right approach or
for visualizing ourselves
or how do you deal with this conception
of time in your own life
yeah you know raphael you're not wrong
to think that you're very very tiny
compared to the universe on the other
hand
you're very very big compared to an
electron uh and on the third hand who
cares
who cares how big you are who cares how
long you're going to last
i do think it's important to appreciate
that we're finite we're ephemeral as i
said in the talk
we're not going to last forever and
therefore whatever it is
that you find meaningful and important
and motivating in your life
it can't be that you're going to leave
an impression on the universe that lasts
literally forever because there are no
such impressions
and i actually find this liberating
rather than leading to existential
despair it takes the burden away from me
to try to do something to the universe
that will actually
leave an imprint that lasts forever the
imprints that we leave on the universe
are finite but that doesn't make them
any less important for that
don't think about the universe think
about the people who you can affect
including yourself uh the impact that
you can have here and in the near future
that's hard enough and it also matters
more than enough i would say
kevin is asking if we know that there's
dark matter and there's
dark energy is there dark time no it's
the equivalent no
all right well because let me amplify
you know
time is not a substance time is not
something you can have a cup of here's a
cup of time
right dark matter is a substance it's a
set of particles you can move it around
you can say oh there's more dark matter
over here than over there
time is a label in modern physics right
it's a it's a way that we think about
where you are in the universe in
space-time
what exists is the universe time is a
language that we use to talk about
the universe so there's no sort of
equivalent different version of time
that would be darker or something like
that now
again having said that there will always
be people who disagree
you know that in the universe in which
we live there's three dimensions of
space
there's one dimension of time so it's
very very natural to say well why aren't
there two dimensions of time or three or
something like that and people have
tried to do that
none of these attempts has really led to
increasing our understanding of the
universe in fact they tend to make
things much much worse
so at least as far as we currently
understand it
the best way of thinking about the
universe is for time to be unique for
there to be one direction of time one
dimension of space-time that we call
the temporal one again as a good
scientist you should always be open to
changing your mind in the future if good
information comes along
and that actually leads into a great
question from uh steven from the
facebook feed
as well um who's asking about some of
the recent quantum
experiments and how they can entangle
the future in the past uh
in some ways there's is that changing
some of notions of causality and
and entropy that maybe there's
connections beyond
between and around the present from the
future impasse
so here i will give you uh my personal
slightly grumpy view about these things
because uh
now we've moved on from time which is
easy to quantum mechanics which is hard
and what i mean by hard is that
the greatest theoretical physicists in
the world don't agree
on how quantum mechanics works what it
says etc i have a point of view
on this i just wrote a book called
something deeply hidden where i explain
to you what my point of view is
but for the purposes of this particular
question here is my point of view
no there's no such thing as entanglement
at different moments of time not really
you
can choose to talk about the quantum
evolution of the universe
in such a way that you can kind of make
sense of such a thing but you don't have
to
when you talk about different uh parts
of the universe at one moment of time
there's an objective fact of the matter
are they entangled with each other or
are they not and everyone agrees on that
and you can talk about it and use it etc
in the conventional way of talking about
quantum mechanics that's all there is
the state of the universe
exists at each moment of time just like
in newtonian physics right in newtonian
physics as we talked about
if you have the positions like the solar
system positions and velocities of
everything at one moment of time
you can predict the past present and
future same thing in quantum mechanics
if you know the quantum state at one
moment of time
you can predict what's going to happen
so i don't personally like to talk about
entanglement between different moments
of time you can but it seems to be just
an attempt to make things seem even more
confusing than they really are
kevin killer is also asking uh how has
your own life changed
since since learning this is this uh
aside from
this is something that you teach but
does this change the way you actually
think about
your the way your life works well um in
a in a fairly
direct way it has because
you know i uh since i was 10 years old i
wanted to be a theoretical physicist
and i read about black holes and the big
bang and particles and
i i did it i eventually you know got to
the point where i was doing that
professionally
um when i was in college as an
undergraduate i also discovered
philosophy
and i fell in love with that also but it
seemed to be like a very different kind
of thing like the kind of philosophy
that i studied was actually
political and moral philosophy and there
was some philosophy of science in there
but uh that wasn't what my favorite kind
of philosophy was
it wasn't until you know i was a
professor already
and i thought a little bit about
cosmology a lot about cosmology actually
but i was thinking about the early
universe
and i got connected with philosophers
who weren't
doing philosophy of science in the sense
they were studying how science works
they were doing philosophy of science in
the sense they were studying how the
universe works
but in a more philosophical way and what
i realized was
they were making more sense when it came
to talking about the universe and time
than my physicist friends were and so i
became more philosophical myself
and that has continued on and i started
thinking about quantum mechanics and how
that works
how time works how space time itself
works how probability works
and these days what i do professionally
in my research career is not even
recognizable as cosmology anymore
so in the down to earth sense that it
has changed my intellectual direction
uh very very much thinking thinking
about time was
my entry into thinking about the
universe in a more philosophical way
nice well and we have a question from uh
toss
rock from youtube it's actually asking
about you know how you
got involved in science and then going
on to doing things like working in the
movie industry and
advising on science fiction movies as we
were just discussing but i think
maybe another way to to think about this
is you know if if somebody
was starting a science career now in in
this space
um what would you tell them what would
you tell them to learn
oh you know what's the interesting space
for a young scientist
to get into so that eventually they get
to be as cool as you advising
marvel honestly there's the two secrets
to becoming a science advisor for
hollywood
are number one live in los angeles
that's where it's located uh number two
have a
at least medium-sized public profile be
out there on social media or writing
books or doing youtube or se
et cetera and they will find you there's
no systematic way you don't apply for a
job
uh it's not a job you don't get paid
it's just kind of fun to talk to uh
directors and screenwriters about their
hollywood movies i got a sweatshirt once
an ironman sweatshirt that was kind of
fun um
but the other version of that question
is you know how do you get into doing
interesting science forgetting about for
the moment uh
movie consulting or anything like that
because there is a fundamental flaw in
the system
where if you're like me uh so i said i
got interested in physics when i was 10
years old so that's the middle
1970s and what are you going to do
you're going to be reading
about what is the most interesting
physics going on
at that point in time so i was reading
about quarks and black holes and the big
bang
and all that is great it's still great
now
but what you do for a living is not
going to be what's interesting when you
first
stumble across the field because there's
decades in between somehow right so
it's very hard to sort of plan ahead for
what will be
the most interesting stuff when you
become a grown-up scientist so
my advice is you know to think broadly
you know to be
open to all the different interesting
things going on um
be ready to say well you know what i
hadn't even thought of this whole
field that seems really cool let me at
least take it seriously you know
learn everything you can and put off to
the last minute choosing once and for
all what has to be your specialty
nice and we're going to be wrapping up
here shortly but i think one of the
things that you said that i thought was
really
interesting is that this idea that while
we have a lot more information about the
past
we obviously have much more influence on
the future i think it's an interesting
thing that in our time actually people
feel as though they're having less and
less influence
on their future uh but i think it's a
nice message this idea that that's
actually the one thing we do have an
influence over and so that physics backs
that up i think is
is really great um and you mentioned one
of your recent books
um what are you what are you working on
now as slash next i know that
this topic was kind of a kind of dipping
into your past a bit but and which i
thank you for but um what what is your
next
current and next uh work well the reason
why i thought
i was very excited about doing this talk
is because even though i wrote a book
on the arrow of time over 10 years ago
now
called from eternity to here uh i'm
actually
again doing research on it so i'm doing
research on this
this question of why is it that
you can have effects and causes but the
effects always come
after the causes in other words why is
the arrow of causality
aligned with the arrow of time you know
i i talk about the arrow of time
a lot of my friends in physics or
philosophy will talk about multiple
different
arrows of time the psychological arrow
the influence that we talked about the
thermodynamic arrow
so one ongoing project is relating them
all
to each other and i'm someone who
believes that the increase of entropy
is the reason why all these other arrows
exist but it's easy to say that out loud
it's hard to prove it with equations
so i'm i'm working on that as a as a
research project using
ideas from causal networks and bayesian
thinking
as well as thermodynamics and entropy
and philosophy of time
cool well thank you so much for joining
us this was so great to have you
and to actually get a kind of a very
fundamental sense of
time and us in it my pleasure xander
thanks very much for having me on
thank you and i'd like to thank you our
along now audience um we actually have
several talks coming up in the future
that cross over uh fundamentals uh in
science such as color
and weather and how trees communicate so
please join us
for the weeks to come
[Music]